all right this is the red carpet debut
for youtubers
it might be it depends we've been to a
couple we're at carpets before oh you i
have okay no actually i remember we flew
from the 2019 when we won we went to a
ticker tip parade and then we came
directly to the space i'm pretty sure
it's an entire team i think of maybe
there's this lady in seattle and your
teammate that would be probably the
biggest power couple on from your team
but you do kind of form a power company
oh a lady in seattle also known as super
yeah that's that lady they're a pretty
awesome power couple
but you two form a power couple also i
like to think so i mean i think power
comes from the inside out and it's like
what you believe that you are you
believe in your value that's something
i've been doing my whole career that's
something that tobin does we believe in
ourselves we have to
so
and let me ask something do you guys
talk does something give you if i do
give tobin advice given me a lot of
advice she's played on the us wins
national team since she was 17. so i
remember before i got my very first cap
i went there and i was like well i don't
play this position tell me what to do um
so it's been a lot of one-way she's the
soccer
expert from young childhood and um but
you're the star and i like excellence i
like being great i like scoring goals so
it works both ways in that way i guess
qualifying what does that mean because i
think there's an expectation now that
y'all will qualify every year and win
the whole damn thing and every year it
gets harder and harder so proud of the
team not only was it the next world cup
but it was the next olympics the first
time the team had to do the both in the
same tournament it's really hard a lot
of pressure
also what does it mean to be here in los
angeles to see the reception of angel
city and how people are
it's been like nothing else in my career
it has been
life-changing to play for my hometown
and these fans it means everything to me
and they turn out i mean it's folks turn
out every week every week and you know
what if there's something special that
happens in the stadium that i can't
explain it you have to come out and
experience it yourself but it's about
something more than sport it's about
progress yeah and it's about pushing
women's
women forward women's sports forward and
it's really beautiful
[Music]